[Music]
I deleted my subredding
because it was trash should I have kept
it down we're gonna find now my friend
hey dude your crush is coming over here
act natural me
my friend hey I'm a depressed 15 year
old me I'm saving lives what a stinker a
celebrating Subway return me not
realizing it was gone
why are you lying I know you all been
crying that the Reddit has been down the
greatest Reddit of all time I'm
surprised the whole world continued to
even function without it found this
picture from 10 years ago when me and
Pete's Sweden Predator spring yeah
that's correct I remember that exact
spot because it's literally outside
where I was living
that jacket that I got was like my first
like oh I have a bit of money now I can
spend it on a nice jacket purchase
hell yeah that's an OG right there I
gotta say was that 10 years ago bruh 10
years
[Music]
isn't it weird like that's completely
different person but I'm it's still me
how does that work
what the [ __ ] am I gonna be in 10 years
this this is what I will be except
natural of course
now actually this uh that's a big slope
it goes like like that and he's like is
it okay if I stand on that I'm like
whatever
makes you feel good seeing Markiplier
has only fans realizing he could upload
the porn video with PewDiePie on there
mark you better not
you promised me Mark has an only fans
what sorry what
all right
but don't post it
supposed to be private before we
continue quick word from sponsor
PewDiePie Rhino Shield collection new
update
look at this look at this no we took
PewDiePie epic design and added optical
illusions to it damn that's trick but I
look at it
ah with five new amazing looking designs
look at these so Prime actually I think
these are my favorite we've ever done
with Rhino Shields they always nail the
designs we also of course have the
classic wave pattern cyberwave and all
the Japanese inspired designs the
classics are still there treat yourself
this holiday season or better yet gift
yourself or someone else because if you
use the code PewDiePie you get 20
discount of the first week so do it now
don't wait late to buy a Christmas gift
don't be one of those with fools the
link will be in the description code
PewDiePie 20 off you're welcome say
thanks
okay I'm still so confused on this meme
I don't understand where it came from
I've never said it he's never said it
I'm being gaslit by my audience that I
[ __ ] another man this does not happen
the Bradley song Final Boss
damn
[Music]
what a close
[Music]
I kind of want it I want it I want that
thing
how do you do behind the throat
yeah okay we get it yeah sure you have a
life yeah pretend you have pretend you
have so much going on pretend like you
went refreshing f5555 every single day
hoping the subway yeah no one's buying
it well it kind of showed how uh it had
gone to [ __ ]
if no one even realized it was gone Mr B
surpasses PewDiePie and Subs 19 year
olds yeah I think that's the only thing
that can stop him now I'm not saying
anyone should of course do anything but
I want you to kill Mr Beast
in fortnite of course
of course he's got a new skin check it
out here's a new problem with the
[ __ ] Reddit which is all the AI art
that's come out and I can't tell I can't
tell I could be like that's amazing you
drew that that's so cool but I'm like
that's probably yeah oh it is says AI
all these artists crying about oh
we're all gonna all gonna be replaced
with AI
OS deal with it please there will be AI
PewDiePie very soon trust me stop
pretending I know you won't care okay
you're not better than me you're not
better than me or anyone I'm better than
you yes
why am I so angry I know this is a lie
how do you accidentally buy a car in
2018 I apparently said that and then at
2022 I accidentally got two cars
whoopsie oopsie it just happened yes yes
this is a more better reaction thank you
it's okay
you you lost something you love and you
had nothing else admit it 15 of my
friends gathered money bought me the 100
Mil chair oh that's so sweet face
friends upload for wholesomeness when
you learn English by watching YouTube
that's very oniony very goody very chewy
what is quail is that a fish I don't
speak it like this you haven't even
heard me try and speak Japanese yet so
you don't even know how bad it can be
every time I try and speak Japanese my
whole face will start sweating
[Music]
just I can tell it's not AI though so
that means it's got to be really good if
anything it just shows your art is bad
if it looks like AI I know that's just a
hot take and I don't mean it don't
cancel the artist that's really cool
upload now now I will not be baited into
feeling bad about a freaking Minecraft
dog how tall am I really big reveal
PewDiePie will most likely turned into a
vlogging Channel when Felix starts a
family with much yeah
oh yeah you think you move it all all
right time to measure
for real
I'm standing up right now two two meters
thank you
so this is it thanks for sticking with
my channel ever since I wasn't I can't
believe he didn't cry during Titanic do
men even have feelings you should have
cried when the Reddit went down this is
cringe he actually found Boots in my
English book that's right I speak at
good English you're welcome he hasn't
got a University degree they really had
to
I had to shove that in there for me
thanks he had to try a different job to
make a living in London oh okay
what
he hasn't got any it scales
what is all this future predictions
where are my glasses
you're not slick how Poots is looking
around hoping to not to get noticed by
fans
so chill in Japan it's quite unusual for
Japanese people to recognize me so when
they do it's they always have some weird
stories it's always kind of cool there
was one guy that said he had been
watching me for 10 years and I was like
yeah sure
and then he was like I I have your face
as my profile picture I was like what it
looked like I don't know 20 at least and
then he had uh he had this photo but my
face replaced with Maya it's
unbelievable
oh my I look so different
oh
I can do that for all
I can do this all day moving on yes yes
this is the right attitude AI art How
Will I Know How will I know it's almost
like the people that say this took me 6
000 years to to draw it how would I know
it could be true it could be not be it
doesn't look real this is real I believe
this is real I help with this big peepee
great philosophers of our time
small PP steroid user I love Japan and
so far it's not even that hot yeah it's
not hot at all I am fine
straw always big peepee drawings love it
you will not be replaced by AI I promise
look at that I survived summer in Japan
thank you whoa you influenced me
personally about so much also your
videos helped me through quite some
doctor that's so nice actually looks
pretty clean AI art
no that's great big poopy AI art
it was great I am joking I'm in the
middle of nowhere and I found one of
these in store why can't I buy them can
we please G fuel get them to Japan
Japan's energy drinks suck so bad this
is the greatest flavor trust me you ever
see it in the store gotta try it they
sell it everywhere apparently even in
middle of nowhere I would like to remind
peers to do a book review and show his
reading list this year I would like to
remind you that I already did one
actually two there's one up for members
only hey you got the Marche version the
greatest version very cute
really
oh the sign is so dirty can someone
please clean sign ah no one give to
Peter can do any but love but what the
heck [ __ ] upstairs but clean this time
please Mr B's crushing peach in sub
count me with my strong belief that puts
is still number one he did it all by
himself that's right all by myself no
one else so I've stopped crying stop it
I never worked with other people ever
all me editing click click click click
click click click where I'm using
Windows Movie Maker
I don't know how you edit I saw puts do
220 pounds in workout video while back
so I had to prove my worth with 220 you
don't have to undo me all right
I can already tell you're a bit too
close
in your grip but maybe you already know
that
damn that was [ __ ] clean too holy
[ __ ] all right well done I take it back
foreign
this reminds me I haven't streamed it
forever
yeah you still always have the 3D stuff
that people did for this Transitions and
stuff I just been busy living life yeah
that's right I have a life okay I have a
life you refresh read it all day I don't
even I never even looked
if it's like about Market really
motivated me to keep going and stay
consistent I almost gave up here's my
progress yeah God damn looking good man
big peepee huge PP glad to know I
inspired you guys that makes me happy AI
this is
that's awesome big poopy the only book
that deserves recognition big big it's
the five year anniversary of meme review
I'm really flies wow well we were oh
[ __ ] and impressive results holy [ __ ]
big peepee holy [ __ ] in a year I've said
it before and I've said it again start
lifting immediately even if you don't
have big peepee you feel like PP huge
all the time extend lifespan actually
that's I don't know if that's a pro or
not but it makes you good it's good do
it all right that's it for a while was
it good that I open it again or should I
ever kept it down let me know in
comments see you next time
that's not my outro
tricked you